our next presenters are what a producer
has in mind when he says get me someone
with class to the classiest performers
around Faye Dunaway and James Garner
the nominees for Best Foreign Language
Film are from France or Wallace on phone
goodbye children muy mal director from
Denmark Babette's feast
Gabrielle Excel director from Spain
horse completed puzzle Jose Luis Garcia
director from Italy the family at door
escola director from Norway Pathfinder
Niles go directly winner is the winner
is Denmark for Babette's feast
except in your ward the film's director
Gabrielle action quickly shot and in
English okay as I went to talk to say
thank you to my podium zone use bed song
and test custom Hanson from the Danish
Felicity to give me the opportunity to
make the Venice feast and of course also
nice people in Denmark 12 make the film
with me I think it was very difficult to
shy to film this film because all the
theme is so different but okay today's
word is by chance
it's the first time a Danish movie can
take in an Oscar home
and therefore I say with Edenic is act
innocent allies a Lea's conviction like
his her general Lavinia in this evening
I have learned that in the beautiful
world of our everything are possible we
shall only await it with confidence and
receive it in gratitude I am very much
grateful for this honor and away and I
want to thank you the Academy members
from the bottom of my heart